bussy rabutin un véritable bijou dans
son écrin
mais lors des fortes pluies l'aller qui
conduit devient un véritable torrent
lors des orages important le wallon ne
conserve plus l'eau depuis la
disparition des haies bocagères et donc
toute l'eau dévale et se précipitent
vers les douves et le château dont nous
devons intervenir ici par un drainage
important de manière à canaliser l'eau
pour qu'elle ne constitue plus un risque
nous avons sollicité cet accompagnement
cette aide de la mission berne pour
déclencher un chantier qui était
indispensable drainage est nécessaire on
l'a constaté depuis plusieurs décennies
et il fallait il fallait lancer ce
chantier est 7e cette enveloppe nous
permet de mettre plus de moyens sur ce
monument pour être chaussée côté gauche
cette pièce sera aménagé pour accueillir
les visiteurs et resituer le château
dans le contexte du grand siècle
mais c'est surtout sur l'ale droite que
vont porter les travaux les plus
conséquents là où les dégâts dus à
l'humidité sont les plus importants il
s'agit ici de purger tout ce qui est à
base de ciment de manière à ce que les
murs puisse de nouveau respirer
il sera donc remplacé par un enduit à
base de chaux
le sable il faudra également refaire les
boiseries que l'on voit ici en piteux
état
une fois ces pièces refaite elles
pourront de nouveau accueillir du
mobilier comme c'est le cas dans les
pièces aujourd'hui visité par le public
la salle des hommes de guerre dont les
visages recouvrent les murs ou encore la
chambre à coucher où le libertin bussy
rabutin fit accrocher les peintures des
femmes qu'ils avaient aimé
tous ces travaux devraient être achevés
au début de l'été 2003